[Music]
in Robbo brainwash news Robo are the
robots getting brainwashed or er the
robos doing the brainwashing I don't
know they're just watching your brain
don't you know how you get a massage and
then you reset your body physically what
if we couldn't mossad your brain I would
love that we reset the birthday what
yeah I think he's got massages recently
there where do you go to get 100 amazing
I mean like a scalp spa yeah it's like
in downtown near downtown what did he do
amazing no it's actually a hair salon
but then they do these collages scalp
they do that after they wash your hair
no it's the whole time that while
they're washing your hair they put all
these like oils and the whole time I
eyes are like back metal like where it
tingles and sometimes you clip this or
something like tea tree or they put like
a whole cap of steams to like open your
follicle whatever and then they massage
a damn tip did you get a brand deal holy
[ __ ] I wish I totally wish Hey see
that's cool well I'm saying but that one
sound too real that red that's that
actually sounded real like a real one
what are you talking about they're all
real no cousin that was like I thought
the passion and then there's the other
one it's like buy this tissue paper cuz
it made my nose so I really like this
psycho entity I did I do huh that's how
he does all's lines and let this make
some no socialist story was submitted by
love from Singapore I want to go to
Singapore we like Singapore we've been
there a study suggests that children are
easily swayed by robots oh do you mean
[ __ ] dumb
children whose way by anything yeah no
you just need a van with candy children
are easily swayed by trains with faces I
love that show
you love that show what's the name of
that show Thomas you does not leave I
love that don't you love that no I
thought it was so cute and now he's like
that [ __ ] sex mom grow up mom that's for
baby
I liked um oh my god not a jerk like
that but I like this a small wonder
yeah member nicci bro and like nobody
knew she was a robot even though she
talked like this I used to get a boner
every time that the reprogram our back
what new her dress I've had to undo it
dress sick I'd be like a four year old
look like a [ __ ] hard-on even though
why every time they had to fix her [ __ ]
I was like manna still charmed dude I
think lamb chop was a scary [ __ ] I ever
saw my whole hand shocked that grandma -
ya know the grandma and she would make
her mouth all where life it she looked
creepy as [ __ ]
look at that doll right now so it's
scarier than [ __ ] so scared than almost
any horror movie monsters we know what's
scarier than that though Oh in Mister
Rogers neighborhood when he went to the
other side with the King and all the
puppets [ __ ] those things are scary trip
dude those are creepy I'm not about I
like the Train though the train was dope
because he [ __ ] went and talked and
he talked and we responded going back
and forth we [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry
did you like that it was like a dog yeah
no my max a laptop so every time I see
girls I have some crazy ass eyelashes
immediately oh yeah oh yeah chop was
enough you probably do too but they
don't know it because they've been
programmed
we did do a generation started singing
it not knowing what it was and they'll
continue singing it forever just because
this is a song you know some people
aren't listening this while they're
driving and they're like where's the
[ __ ] knob yeah another [ __ ] is
gonna crash lamb chop I've never seen
that [ __ ] I don't like five or four so
it's like by the time I was able to
remember [ __ ] it was already gone Oh
anyway this article has a LED candy why
actually alright so there was his
research conducted at the University of
Plymouth and they found that adults are
not swayed by robots that they are
earrin aren't some adults we did another
article where they had that little robot
they're like please don't turn me off
I'm going dark please oh I would be
swayed by that robot yeah especially
this is [ __ ] yeah exactly yeah and in
those sex robots with a badass resist it
if they said like put quarters on my
tray I just [ __ ] it I don't know what
robot I would be maybe they see one if
it's cute yeah if it's cute and it was
like doing a sad kind of story but if it
was like don't you dare turn me up I
would destroy that they burn it but
that's why robot will never do that
they'll always be cute even while they
destroy the earth they'll be cute as
[ __ ] that's the whole thing he's gonna
be a bunch of cute little babies coming
in with missiles and [ __ ] oh ya know
they'll make the missiles cute and the
missiles will talk
[Music]
and then [ __ ] new I don't think I
would fear death then at that point well
[ __ ] done or humans would evolve to
not like anything cute anymore oh but
that will take [ __ ] thousands of
years you always mind [ __ ] me you always
yes I'll be in the study they completed
this test known as the ushe ashed
paradigm where it involves finding two
lines that match in length and so this
is known as a conformity experiment
because the test has historically found
that people tend to agree with their
peers even if individually they have a
different idea that's true true so then
in this case of yours those mob
mentality things yeah you know well
that's because you want to hurt people's
feelings and stuff to also cuz we live
in the land of feelings aka in
California
I don't think Jo has won what she just
said where you're more likely to agree
with your peers even if you individual
I'm agreeable I think right now you're
disagreeing we got that ya know I don't
know I don't I don't know it's more to
say because you know in the moment it
depends on what it is I think if it's
not worth causing disharmony in the
group I'll go with it that's true oh
yeah it's not that big of a deal so then
if you're comparing two lines to see the
length you wouldn't any people go that
looks like the same leg that the maybe
it depends on what's at stake you know
like am I gonna fight about it yeah [ __ ]
it yeah it is it's it's it's fine
right versus it's a million dollars is
on staking we have to be a hundred
percent correct I'm like shut the [ __ ]
up you guys that's wrong and we're green
eat that million dollars right now true
I need them yeah I want that we're gonna
have this test no where's the lines with
were they show us the lines why is this
line so profitable I'm ready so in this
case there appears that they were
conducting this test what was war what
are you told all the dogs watch don't
look girls take off their dresses
yeah so the peers were robots is what I
was trying to say the kid they were aged
seven seven to nine and when they were
alone in the room they scored an average
of 87% on the test but then when the
robots joined them their scores dropped
to 75 percent on average and of the
wrong answers 74% of them matched those
of the robots so they were being
influenced by whatever the robot was
saying oh because it looks like an
authority figure that knows
exactly you don't think computers can
fail well and like when you're a kid
like all the things are there to help
you and educate you like all and so
you're just used to the thing being
right yeah even as an adult if the robot
would tell me like this I'll just I just
do it because I don't want to think well
the adults in this this test here study
they did not conform to what the robots
were saying they start to learn I'm
proud of them and so the whole point of
all this there's a small percentage that
did agree right
but I think it also depends on right it
depends on the subject right because if
it's like something like the sky is red
maybe a kid would probably be like oh
maybe maybe I'm [ __ ] up it yeah it is
red you know but then it's adult adults
ask the same question it's like no [ __ ]
you you're obviously wrong I think it
depends on one thing
think about how crazy it is just say
like well a robot told me some [ __ ] like
right now that's crazy but in like 10
years it's not gonna be that crazy to
say like Oh robot told me like this
exactly so the way that society is
moving forward especially with robots in
our daily lives in the future
they're saying here that children will
be increasingly more susceptible to
pressure from
robot so like if let's say if marketing
companies started using these robots to
market certain products to children
they're gonna be brainwashed and
together these everything evolves
because like if exactly the like right
now we wouldn't fall for the same
marketing tricks as they used in the
1950s where everybody it just was
different back name because as a kid I
would believe every single commercial I
would watch yeah that was my our robots
through the commercials that they would
play right we're breaking advertisers
balls right now because we have been
trained since we were kids with
computers to like be able to click out
of ads quickly
yeah and we're [ __ ] them over pretty
hard like the way that we and we have
things called ad blocker yeah and your
parents can feel like robots are shady
don't listen to it Oh interesting you
know don't be such a facet of our
society in the next decade she's so new
right now that the kids are like a
picture of what the robot looks like
well again similar to that one robot
that I showed you the video the dead
prostitute no the guy looks like a
superhero yes Qi because I was picturing
like some [ __ ] post-apocalyptic like
steampunk robot I was picturing like
that Terminator head yeah I would be so
sad if I take this test and they don't
let me keep that robot like at that age
I want that [ __ ] robot that's true
what a badass robot babysitter's think
about that babysitters are [ __ ] dude if
you're a babysitter out there
you better be starting looking for a
real career dude cuz you guys are [ __ ]
real and I think waitresses like servers
and restaurants cuz truck drivers l
[ __ ] dude we're gonna turn it to the
Jetsons I know why you think the robots
would be able to flirt better than a
waitress what do you think that's what
waitresses yeah truck drivers that's why
they want them but they could flirt with
what a little bit more entertainment
they stand on chairs you know what do
they do so the test runs is like which
line is the closest in an obvious it's
the middle one right so that insert a
kid going to the middle they just see
what the robots choose yeah and they
want to choose what the robots choose
exactly of course a [ __ ] adult is
gonna be like no robot
yeah and their programming there ought
to give the wrong answer those to prove
that children are susceptible exact
everything which we already knew that
know between oh you said talking trains
no no I go up to a stranger's kid and
tell them hey I'm gonna tell your
parents that you're doing something bad
even if they're not doing something bad
and then they would be like oh my god
let me trouble so this research is
important because they are calling for
the robotics community to build in
safeguards for children now that they
actually have this fruit yeah that's a
ethical release Wade
yep dude the most viewed [ __ ] on YouTube
it's like adults who are like faking
mysteries for kids right like it's like
oh hey I um
you know I woke up on a [ __ ] beach or
whatever like I I'm walking through a
cave a mysterious cave and I'm
completely alone right now but obviously
somebody's telling me but the kids don't
know that's it they don't think like Oh
somebody's filming him you can't see the
motion of this [ __ ] but like kids
getting tricked they're susceptible to
these things is like a lucrative I know
you could have industry I don't know why
they do that
hey like right now if you want us to
explain why this happens to kids just
hit the like button and then we'll start
doing it exactly but we're not gonna do
it if you don't like yeah the like
button as fast as you can away also
comment down what people need to do it
well otherwise we can't explain do you
guys want Joe to wear this blue shirt or
should you turn into a red shirt if you
can't do comment below right now then
we'll do we might change
Oh what's gonna happen
[Music]
[Music]